The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, well,
good afternoon and welcome back.
We have an exciting fun-filled
program for you this afternoon.
I'm David Gifford.
I'm delighted to
be back with you
again, here in computational
systems biology.
Today we're going to talk
about chromatin structure
and how we can analyze it.
And to give you the narrative
arc for our discussion today,
we're first going to
begin with looking
at computational methods that
we can break the, quote unquote
code, that describes
the epigenome.
Now, epigenetic state is
extraordinarily important
and one way you
can visualize this
is that the genome is
like a hotel filled
with lots of different rooms.
And a lot of the doors are
locked and some of the doors
are unlocked.
And only in the doors
that we can go into,
where the genome is
open and accessible
can there actually be work
done, regulation performed
and transcripts
and proteins made.
So we're going to talk about
how to actually analyze
epigenetic state.
And then we're going
to talk about how
to use epigenetic
information to understand
the entire regulatory
occupancy of the genome.
We've already talked about
ChIP-seq and the idea
that we can understand where
individual regulators sit
on the genome, and how they
regulate proximal genes.
We're now going to see if we
can learn more about the genome.
How it's state-- whether
it's open or closed.
Is it self-regulated?
And answer a puzzle.
The puzzle is, if there
are hundreds of thousands
of possible binary
locations that
are equally good
for a regulator,
why are only tens of
thousands occupied?
And how are those sites picked?
Because that level of regulation
is extraordinarily important
to establish a basal
level of what genes
are accessible and operating.
And finally, we're going to
talk about how we can map,
which regulatory
regions in the genome
are affecting which genes.
It turns out that about
1/3 of the regulatory sites
in the genome skip over a
gene that's closest to them
to regulate a gene
that's farther away.
This is a million genomes.
And so given that
rough approximation,
how is it that we
can make connections
between regulatory sites and
the genes that they control?
Now, in computational
systems biology,
we always talk a
lot about biology,
but we also need to reflect
upon the computational methods
that we're bringing to
bear on these questions.
And so, today, we're
going to be talking
about three different methods.
We'll talk about dynamic
Bayesian networks as a way
to approach, understanding
the histone code.
We'll talk about how to
classify factor binding,
using log likelihood ratios.
And finally, we'll
turn to our friend,
the hypergeometric
distribution to analyze
which locations
in the genome are
interacting with one another.
So let's begin with
establishing a vocabulary.
I'm sure some of you
have seen this before.
This is the way
that chromatin can
be thought of being organized
at different levels.
There's the primary
DNA sequence,
which can include
methylated CPGs.
That's cysteine,
phosphate, guanine.
And the nice thing about
that is that it's symmetrical
so that when you have a CPG,
a methyltransferase during DNA
replication can copy
that methy mark over.
So it's a mark that's heritable.
The next level down
are histone tails.
On the amino terminus
of histones H3 and H4,
different chemical
modifications can be made,
and they serve as
sign posts, as we'll
see, to give us
clues about what's
going on in the genome in
that proximal location.
The next level down
is, whether or not
the chromatin is
compacted or not.
Whether it's open or closed.
And that relates
to whether or not
DNA binding proteins are
actually on the genome.
And finally, certain
domains of the genome
can be associated with
the nuclear lamina.
And so they're different levels
of organization of chromatin.
And we'll be exploring
all of these today.
So the cartoon
version of the way
that the genome is
organized is that at the top
we have a transcribed gene.
And you can see that
there's an enhancer that
is interacting with the RNA
polymerase II start site.
And you can see
varied histone marks
that are associated with
this activated gene.
There are also marks
that are associated
with that active enhancer.
Down below, you see
an inactive gene.
And you can see that there's
a boundary element that's
bound by CTCF, which,
one of its function
is to serve as a genomic
insulator, which insulates
the effect of the enhancer
above from the gene below.
So through careful biochemical
analysis over the years,
these different marks have been
analyzed and characterized.
And a general paradigm
for understanding
how the marks transition
as genes are activated
is shown here.
So genes that are
fairly active and cycle
between active and
inactive states typically
have a high CPG content
in their promoters.
And transition is
shown on the left.
Where in the repressed
state on the bottom,
they're marked by
H3K27 trimethyl marks.
When they're poised, they have
both H3K4 trimethyl and H3K27
trimethyl.
And when they're active, they
only have H3K4 trimethyl.
And on the right hand side are
genes that are less active.
So in their completely shut down
state, they may have no marks,
but the DNA is
methylated, silencing
that region of the genome.
And other marks then,
culminating in H3K4 trimethyl
once again when they
become active at the top.
So I'm summarizing
for you here, decades
of research in histone marks.
And it has been
summarized in figures
like this, where you can
look at different classes
of genetic elements-- whether
they be promoters in front
of genes, gene bodies
themselves, enhancers,
or the large scale
repression of the genome--
and you can look
at the associated
marks with those
characteristic elements.
OK, so, how can we
learn this de novo?
That is, you could
memorize, and of course it's
important to
understand, for example,
if you want to look
for active enhancers
in the genome, that
looking for things
like H3K4 monomethyl and H3K7
27 acetyl marks together,
would give you a good clue
where the enhancers are
in the genome that are active.
But if we want to
learn all this de novo,
without having to memorize it
or rely upon the literature,
the great thing is that there's
a lot of data out there now
that characterizes, or profiles
all these marks, genome-wide,
in variety of cellular states.
And there's the epigenome
roadmap initiative
to look at this in hundreds
of different cell types.
So, what is the histone code?
That is, how can we
unravel the different marks
present in the genome and
understand what they mean?
Because the genome doesn't come
ready-made with those little
cute labels that we had on
it-- enhancer, gene body,
and so forth.
So somehow, if we
want to understand
the grammar of the
genome and its function,
we're going to need to be
able to annotate it, hopefully
with computational help.
So here's a picture of
what typical data looks
like along the genome.
So, obviously you can't
read any of the legends
on the left-hand side.
If you want to look
at the slides that
are posted on Stellar, you
can see the actual marks.
But the reason I posted
this is because you
can see the little pink
thing at the top-- that's
where the RNA transcript has
been mapped to the genome.
The actual annotated
genes are above.
And then down below you
can see a whole collection
of histone marks and other
kinds of chromatin information
that have been
mapped to the genome
and spatially
create patterns that
are suggestive of the function
of the genomic elements,
if they're properly interpreted.
And below, you see in blue,
the binding of different TFs,
as determined by ChIP-seq.
So, what we would
like to do then,
is to take this
kind of information
and automatically learn,
or automatically annotate
the genome as to its
functional elements.
Let me stop here and
ask, how many people
have seen histone mark
information before?
OK.
And how many people have
used it in their research?
Not too many-- a couple people?
OK.
So it's getting
quite easy to collect
and there are a couple of ways
of analyzing this kind of data,
genome-wide.
One way is that we could
run a hidden Markov
model over these data
and predict states
at regular intervals.
For example, every 200
bases down the genome,
and see how the HMM transition
from state to state and let
the state suggest what the
underlying genome elements
that we're doing.
Another way is to use a
dynamic Bayesian network.
So a dynamic Bayesian network
is simply a Bayesian network.
We've talked about those before.
And it models data
sampled along the genome.
And so it's a directed
acyclic graph.
There are tools out
there that allow
us to learn these
models directly.
And it allows us, as we'll
see, to analyze the genome
at high resolution, and
to handle missing data.
So we'll be talking
about Segway,
which is a particular
dynamic Bayesian network that
takes the kind of data
we saw on the slide
before and essentially parses
it into labels that allow us
to assign function to
different genomic elements.
And it does this in
an unsupervised way.
What I mean by that is
that it is automatically
learning the states,
and then afterwards we
can look at the states and
assign meaning to them.
So here is the dynamic Bayesian
network that Segway uses.
And let me explain
this somewhat scary
looking diagram of lots of
little boxes and pointers
to you.
The genome is described
through the variables
on the bottom-- the
observation variables,
going from left to
right, where each base is
a separate observation
variable which consists
of the level of a
particular histone mark
at a particular based position
as described by mapped
reads to that location.
The little square
box-- the little boxes
that says "x" on it with the
other small print you can't
read-- is simply an
indicator, whether or not
the data is present.
If the data is absent, we
don't try and model it.
If that box contains a zero,
we don't model the data.
If the box is one, then we
attempt to model the data.
And the most important part of
the dynamic Bayesian network
is the q box above, where
those are the states.
And each state describes an
ensemble of different histone
marks that are output.
And so the key thing
is that for each state
we learn what marks
it's outputting.
And the model learns
this automatically
through a learning phase.
The boxes above
simply are a counter.
And the counter allows us
to define maximum lengths
for particular states, so
states don't run on forever.
So unlike a hidden
Markov model that
doesn't have that
kind of control,
we can adjust how long we
want the states to last.
So this model, if you
turned it 90 degrees
and rotated it clockwise,
would be more familiar to you
because all the arrows
would be flowing
from the top of the screen down.
There are no cycles in this
directed acyclic graph.
And therefore, it can be
probabilistically viewed
and learned in
the same framework
that we learn a
Bayesian network.
In fact, it is a
The reason it's
called dynamic is
because we are learning
temporal information,
or in this case,
spatial information
with these different
observations
along the bottom of the model.
Now before I go on,
perhaps somebody
could ask me a question
about the details
of these dynamic
Bayesian networks,
because the ability to
automatically assign labels
to genome function, given
the histone marks is really
a key thing that's gone on
the last couple of years.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you
re-explain that--
what the labeled-- the second
[INAUDIBLE] was all about?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So the Q label is right
here, these labels.
And each of these
Q labels defines
one of a number of states.
For example, 24
different states.
In a given state, describes
the expected output
in terms of what histone marks
are present in that state.
So it's going to
describe the means of all
those different histone marks.
24 different means,
let's say, of the marks
it's going to output.
And the job of fitting the model
is picking the right states,
or a set of 24
states, each of which
is most descriptive of its
particular subset of chromatin
marks.
And then defining how we
transition between states.
So we not only need to
define what a state means
in terms of the marks
that it outputs, but also
when we transition from
one state to another.
Does that make sense to you?
AUDIENCE: So I know it
states the information that
tells at each of the Q boxes.
Is that a series
of probabilities?
Or is it something else?
PROFESSOR: It's actually
a discrete number, right.
So it actually is a
single-- there's only
a single state in each Q box.
So it might be a
number between 1 and 24
that we're going to learn.
And based upon
that number, we're
going to have a
description of the marks
that we would expect to
see at the observation
at that particular
genomic location.
And so our job here is to
learn those 24 different states
and what they output
in the training phase,
and then once we've
trained the model,
we can go back and look
at other held out data,
and then we can
decode the genome.
Because we know what
the states are, and we
know what they are
supposed to be producing,
we can use a Verterbi decoder
and go back and-- as we
did with the HMM and we
learned the HMM-- go back
and read off on the
histone mark sequence
and figure out what
their relative states are
for each base position
of the genome.
Is that helpful?
Yes?
Any other questions about
dynamic Bayesian networks?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you choose
the number of states?
PROFESSOR: That's a
very good question.
How do you choose
the number of states?
Well, if you choose
too many states,
they obviously don't
really become descriptive
and you can become
over fit and then
can start fitting
noise to your model.
And if you choose too few
states, what will happen
is, that states can
get collapsed together
and they won't be
adequately descriptive.
The answer is, it's more
or less trial and error.
There really isn't
a principled way
to choose the right
number of states
in this particular context.
Now, you could do--
AUDIENCE: What's
the trial, then?
You run it and you
get a set of things,
and what do you do
with those labels?
PROFESSOR: What do
you do with labels?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, how
do you evaluate it?
PROFESSOR: You
typically, in both
of these cases-- both in the
case of chrome HMM and this--
you rely upon the
previous literature.
And we saw on that
slide earlier,
what marks are associated
with what kinds of features.
So you use the prior
literature and you
use what the states are telling
you they're describing to try
and associate those
states with what's
known about genome function.
All right, yes?
AUDIENCE: Where does that
information concerning
the distance between
states go again?
Like, the counter?
Like, how does that
control how long
the states go on
and whether or not--
PROFESSOR: What happens is that
the counter at the top, the C
variables, influence the J
variables you can see there.
When the J variable
terms to a 1,
it forces the state transition.
So the counters count
down and can then
force a state
transition which will
cause the Q variable to change.
It's sort of a-- that particular
formulation of this model
is a bit of a, sort
of Rube Goldberg kind
of hackish kind of thing.
I think to make it get
out of particular states.
But it works, as we'll
see in just a moment.
OK.
So here's an example
of it operating.
And you can see the different
states on the y-axis here.
You can see the different
state transitions
as we go down the genome.
And you can see the
annotations that it's
outputting, corresponding
to the histone marks.
And so what this
is doing is it's
decoding for us what it thinks
is going on in the genome,
solely with reference
to the histone marks,
without reference to primary
sequence or anything else.
And this kind of
decoding is most useful
when we want to discover things
like regulatory elements.
When we want to look for H3K4
mono or dimethyl, and H3K27
acetyl for example, and identify
those regions of the genome
that we think are
active enhancers.
OK.
So, any questions at all about
histone marks and decoding?
Do you get the
general idea that you
can assay these histone
marks through ChIP-seq using
antibodies that are specific
to a particular mark.
Pull down the histones that
are associated with DNA
with that mark and map
them to the genome.
So we get one track for
each ChIP-seq experiment.
We can profile all the marks
that we think are relevant,
and then we can look at
what those parks imply
about both the static
structure of our genome,
and also how it's being
used as cells differentiate
or in different
environmental conditions.
OK.
So, let's go on, then,
to the next step, which
is that if we understand the
sort of epigenetics state,
how is that established and
how is the opening of chromatin
regulated and how is it that
factors find particular places
in the genome to bind?
So, the puzzle I talked
to you about earlier
was that there are
hundreds of thousands
of particular motifs
in the genome,
but a very small
number are actually
bound by regulatory factors.
And you might think
that the difference
is that the ones that are bound
have different DNA sequences.
But in fact, on the
right-hand side, what we see
is that identical DNA sequences
are bound differentially
in two different conditions.
Shown there are
sites that are only
bound, for example,
in endodermal tissues
or in ES cells.
So it isn't the sequence
that's controlling
the specificity of the
binding, it's something else.
And we'd like to figure out
what that something else is.
We'd like to understand
the rules that
govern where those factors
are binding in the genome.
So a set of factors are
known that bind to the genome
and open it.
They're called pioneer factors.
There are some well known
pioneer factors like FoxA
and some of the iPS
reprogramming factors.
And the idea is that
they're able to bind
to closed chromatin
and to open it up
to provide accessibility
to other factors.
So what we would
like to do, is to see
if there's a way that we
could, both understand
how to discover those
factors automatically,
using a computational
method, and secondarily,
understand where factors are
binding in a single experiment
across the genome.
So the results I'm going to
show you can be summarized here.
I'm going to show
you a method called
PIQ that can predict where
TFs bind from DNase-seq data
that I'll describe in a moment.
We'll identify pioneer factors.
We'll show that certain of these
pioneer factors are directional
and only operate in
one way on the genome.
And finally, that the
opening of the genome
allow subtler factors to come
in and to bind to the genome.
So let's begin with
what DNase-seq data is,
and how we can use
it to predict where
TFs are binding to the genome.
So DNase-seq is a
methodology for exploring
what parts of the
genome are open.
So here's the idea.
You take your cell
and you expose it,
once you've isolated the
chromatin to DNase-1 which
will cut or nick
DNA at locations
where the DNA is open.
You then can collect the
DNA, size separate it
and sequence it.
And thus, you're
going to have more
reads where the
DNA has been open,
and less reads were it's
protected by proteins.
So the cartoon below
gives you an idea
that, where there are
histones-- each histone
has about 147 bases of
DNA wrapped around it.
Or where there are other
proteins hiding the DNA,
you're going to cast
shadows on this.
So we're going to be looking
at the shadows and also
the accessible parts,
by looking directly
at the DNase-seq reads.
So if we sequence
deeply enough we
can understand that
each binding protein has
its own particular
profile of protection.
So if you look at these
different proteins,
they cast particular
shadows on the genome.
I'm showing here a window
that's 400 base pairs wide.
This is the average of thousands
of different binding instances.
So this is not one binding
instance on the top row.
You can see how CTCF
and other factors
have particular shadows
they cast or profiles.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you know
which factor was at which site?
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: How do we know
which factor is at which site?
By the motifs that
are under the site.
And what's
interesting about CTCF
is that you can actually see
how it phase the nucleosomes.
You can see the, sort of,
periodic pattern in CTCF.
And those dips are where
the nucleosomes are.
There's a lot you can
tell from these patterns
about the underlying molecular
mechanism of what's going on.
Now, you can see at the very
bottom, the aggregate CTCF
profile.
And if all the CTCF
bindings looked like that,
it'd be really easy.
But above it, as I've shown
you what an individual CTCF
site looks like, you can
see how sparse it is.
We just don't get
enough re-density to be
able to recover a beautiful
protection profile like that.
So we're always working
against a lot of noise
in this kind of
biological environment.
And so our
computational technique
will need to come up
with an adequate model
to overcome that noise.
But if we can, right,
the great promise
is that with a single
experiment we'll
be able to identify where all
these different factors are
binding to the genome
from one set of data.
So, just reiterating now,
if you think about the input
to this algorithm-- we're
going to have three things
that we input to the algorithm.
We input the original
genome sequence.
We input the motifs
of the factors
that we care about, that
we think are interesting.
And we input the
DNase-seq data that
has been aligned to the genome.
So those are the three inputs.
And the output of
the algorithm is
going to be the predictions
of which motifs are occupied
by the factors,
probabilistically.
And in order to do
that, for each protein
we need to learn its
protection profile.
And we need to
score that profile
against each
instance of the motif
to see whether or not we
think the protein is actually
sitting at that
location in the genome.
Any questions at all about that?
No?
OK.
Don't hesitate to stop me.
So the design goals for this
particular computational
algorithm, as I said earlier,
is resistance to low coverage
and lots of noise.
To be able to handle
multiple experiment once,
it has to work on the
entire mammalian genome.
It has to have high
spatial accuracy
and it has to have good
behavior in bad cases.
So in order to model the
underlying re-distribution
of the genome, what
we're going to do
is something that
is in principle
quite straightforward.
Which is that we're going to
model all accounts that we
see in the genome by a
Poisson distribution.
So in each base of
the genome, the counts
that we see there in
the DNase-seq data
are modeled by a Poisson.
And this is assuming that
there's no protein bound there.
So what we're trying to do
is to model the background
distribution of counts
without any kind of binding.
And the log rate
of that Poisson is
going to be taken from
a multivariate normal.
And the particular structure
of that multivariate normal
provides a lot of smoothing.
So we can learn from
that multivariate normal
how to fill in
missing information.
It's very important
to build strength
from neighboring bases.
So, even though we may not
have lots of information
for this base, if
we have information
for all the bases around us,
we can use that information
to build strength to estimate
what we should see at this base
if it's not occupied.
So the details of how we
learn the mean and the sigma
matrix you see up
there for estimating
the multivariate normal
are outside the scope
of what I'm going
to talk about today.
But suffice to say, they
can be effectively learned.
And the second thing we need
to learn are these profiles.
And so each protein is
going to have a profile.
Here shown 400 bases wide.
And it describes how that
protein, so to speak,
casts a shadow on the genome.
And we judge the significance
of these profiles--
and remember that
one of my points
was I wanted this to be robust.
So I will not make calls for
proteins where I cannot get
a robust profile that is
significant above background.
And I also exclude the
middle region of the profile
because it's been shown that
the actual cutting enzymes are
sequence specific
to some extent.
The DNase-1 cutting enzyme.
And so we don't
simply want to be
but picking up sequence
bias in our profile.
So we learn these
profiles that describe
for each particular
motif-- and typically we
can take in hundreds of motifs,
over 500 motifs at once--
for each motif, what its
protection looks like.
So what we then have-- we're
going to learn this, actually,
in an iterative process, but
what we're going to have is--
now we have a model of what the
unoccupied genome looks like.
And we have a model of the
reads that a particular protein
at a motif location
is going to produce.
And we can put those two
things together and the way
that we do that is that we
have a binding variable.
Showing there is delta.
And we can either add or
not add the binding profile
of a particular protein in
a location in the genome.
And that will change the
expected number of counts
that we see.
So the key part of this is that
we use a likelihood ratio shown
as the second probability.
It's not really a
probability, it's
a ratio, which is the
probability of a count, given
that a protein j is
binding at that location,
versus the probability of the
counts, were it not binding.
And that quantity
is key because it's
going to be-- once
we log transform it,
will be a key component
of our test statistic
to figure out whether
or not a protein's
binding at a
particular location.
And so the way that we go about
that is it we log that ratio
and we add it to some other
prior information that gives us
an overall measure
for whether or not
the protein is binding
at a particular location.
And then we can rank
these for all the motifs
for that particular
protein in the genome.
And then we can make
calls using a null set.
So we could look in the
genome for locations
that we know are not occupied,
compute a distribution
of that statistic,
and then we can say,
for what values of this
statistic that we observe,
at the actual motif sites,
is it so unlikely that this
would occur at random.
At some desired p
value by looking
at the area in the
tail of the null set.
So, just summarizing, we
learn a background model
of the genome, which
is a Poisson that
takes log rates from
a multivariate normal.
We learn patterns, or
profiles of protection,
or the production of
reads for each motif.
And at each motif location,
we ask the question
whether or not, it's
likely that the protein
was there and actually caused
the reads that we're seeing,
using a log likelihood ratio.
So what we're
integrating together,
when we take all
these things, is
that we're taking our
original DNA seq-reads,
we're taking our TF-specific
specific binding profiles.
We can build strength across
experiments for the background
model and we can also learn,
to what extent, the strength
of binding is influenced by
the match of the position--
a specific weight matrix--
to a particular location
in the genome.
And then we can
produce binding calls.
And when we do so,
it works quite well.
So here you see three
different mouse ESO factors.
And the area under
this receiver operating
curve-- we've talked
about this before.
Remember a receiver
operating characteristic
curve-- has false
positives increasing
on the x-axis and true positives
increasing on the y-axis.
And if we had a perfect method,
the area under that curve
would be 1.0.
And so for this method,
the area under the ROC
curve for these three
factors, using ChIP-seq data,
is the absolute gold
standard, is over 0.9.
And you might say,
well that's great,
but how well does
it work in general?
I mean, for example,
the On-code project
has used hundreds and hundreds
of ChIP-seq experiments
to profile where
factors are binding
in different cellular states.
If you take the DNase-seq data
from those matched cell types
and you ask, can you reproduce
the ChIP-seq seq data?
The answer is, a lot
of the time we can,
using this kind of methodology.
And that is, the
AUC mean is 0.93
compared to 313 different
ChIP-seq experiments.
So this methodology of
looking at open chromatin
allows us to identify where
lots of different factors
bind to the genome.
And about 75 different
factors are strongly
detectable using
this methodology.
So it's detectable if
it has a strong motif,
if it binds in
DNase-accessible regions
and has strong
DNA-binding affinity.
So I tell you this
just so you know
that there are
new methods coming
that allow us to take
a single experiment
and analyze it and determine
where a large number of factors
bind from that single
experimental data set.
Now, a second question
we wanted to answer
was, how is it that chrome,
opening and closing is
controlled?
And since we had a direct read
out of what chromatin is open,
because reads are
being produced there,
we could look in a
experimental system
where we measured
chromatin accessibility
through developmental time.
And the idea was that as we
measured this accessibility,
we could look at the
places that changed
and determine what underlying
motifs were present that
perhaps were causing the
genome to undergo this opening
process.
So we developed an
underlying theory
that pioneer factors would bind
to closed chromatin as shown
in the middle panel
and open it up,
and that we could observe those
by looking at the differential
accessibility of the genome
at two different time
points that were related.
And we couldn't observe pioneers
they didn't open up chromatin.
And for non-pioneers--
obviously the left-hand panel--
they would not, in
our design here,
lead to increased accessibility.
So we then looked at designing
computational indices that
measured the--
oh, question, yes?
AUDIENCE: When you
say pioneer factors,
are you looking at what proteins
are pioneer factors, or are you
looking at what sequences they
bind to that are [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, are we
looking at what
proteins are factors,
or are we looking at
what sequence, right?
What we're doing is,
we're making an assumption
that the underlying sequence
denotes one or more proteins
and thus, we are
hypothesizing, there's
the proteins that are actually
binding to the sequence, that's
causing that.
And then later on, we'll go back
and test that experimentally,
as you'll see in a second.
OK?
So here there are three
different metrics,
which is the dynamic opening
of chromatin from one time
point to the next, the
static openness of chromatin
around a particular factor,
and a social index showing
how many other factors
are around where
a particular factor binds.
And you can see that these
things are distributed in a way
that certain of the factors have
a very high index in multiple
of these scores.
And thus, we were
able to classify
a certain set of factors
as what we classified
as computational pioneers,
that would open up the genome.
Now, in any kind of
computational work,
we're actually looking
at correlative analysis,
which is never causal.
Right.
So we have to go back and we
have to test whether or not
our computational
predictions are correct.
So in order to do
that, we built a test
construct where we
could put the pioneers
in on the left-hand side
and ask, whether or not
the pioneer would
open up chromatin
and enable the expression
of a GFP marker.
And the red bars
show the factors
that we thought were pioneers.
And as you can see, in
this case, all but one
of the predictive pioneers
produces GFP activity.
And this construct was
designed in an interesting way.
We had to design it so that
the pioneers themselves
were not simply activators.
And so it was upstream of
another activator, which
is a retinoic acid
receptor site.
And so in the absence of
retinoic acid receptor,
we had to ensure that when
we turned on the pioneer,
GFP was not turned on.
It was only with the
addition of the pioneer
to open the chromatin
and the activator
that we actually
got GFP expression.
OK.
So, through this
methodology we discovered
about 120 different motifs
corresponding to proteins
that we found computationally
open-- chromatin out.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
concentrations
of different pioneer
factors are different,
wouldn't that show up
differentially [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The question
is, if the concentration
of different pioneer
factors was different,
wouldn't that show
up differentially?
And that's precisely, we
think how chromatin structures
are regulated.
That we think that the
concentration, or presence
of different pioneer factors,
is regulating the openness
or closeness of different
parts of the genome,
based upon where their
motifs are occurring.
Is that, in part,
answering your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, but,
if a concentration
of a particular
pioneer factor is low,
do they necessarily have lesser
binding sites on the genome?
PROFESSOR: So you're
asking, how is
the concentration
of a pioneer factor
related to its ability
to open chromatin
and whether or not a
higher dosage would
open more chromatin?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: I don't have a
good answer to that question.
Those experiments
haven't been done.
However, one thing you may have
noticed about these profiles--
remember these are the same
profiles that we talked
about earlier of DNase-1
read reproduction
around a particular factor.
And what you might notice is
that some of these profiles
are asymmetric.
And that they appear to be
producing more region one
direction than the
other direction.
And so this is all
computational analysis, right.
But when you see
something like that you
say, well gee, why
is that going on?
Why is it that for NRF-1 the
left-hand side has a lot more
reads than the right hand side.
Now, of course, the only reason
that we can produce an oriented
profile like that is that the
NRF-1 motif is not palindromic,
right.
We can actually orient
it in the genome
and so we know that the
more reads, in this case,
are coming from
the five prime end
then from the three prime end.
So what do you think
would cause that?
Does anybody have a--
when we first saw this,
we didn't know what it was.
But anybody have an idea
of what that could be?
Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: It's the remodelers
that these transcription
factors are calling in tend to
open the chromatin more on one
side of the motif
than the other.
PROFESSOR: Right,
so if the remodelers
are working in some sort
of directional way, right.
So that's what we thought.
We didn't know whether
they were or not.
And so we went back to our
assay and we tested the motifs,
both in the forward and
the reverse direction.
Right.
To see whether or
not it mattered
which way the motif
went into the construct,
based upon selecting factors,
based upon a symmetry
score that we computed for
their read profile, right?
And what we found was that, in
fact, it was the case that when
the motif was properly
oriented it would turn on GFP
and was in the other
direction it would not.
So it appeared, for the
factors that we tested,
that they did have directional
chromatin opening properties.
And so that's an
interesting concept
that you actually
can have chromatin
being opened in one direction
but not the other direction,
because it admits
the idea of some sort
of genomic parentheses,
where you could imagine
part of the genome
being accessible where
the other part is not.
And overall this led us to
classifying protein factors
that are operating in
genome accessibility
into three classes.
Here shown as two, where
we have pioneers which
are the things that
open up the genome,
and settlers that follow
behind and actually
bind in the regions where
the chromatin is open.
That is, it's much more likely
that those factors are going
to bind where the doors
of the rooms are open,
and the pioneers are
the proteins that
come along and open the doors,
in particular, chromatin
domains.
And there were a couple of other
tests that we wanted to do.
We wanted to test whether
or not we could knock out
this pioneering activity by
taking a pioneer and just
only including its
DNA-binding domain
and knocking out the
rest of its domain
which might be operative
in doing this chromatin
remodeling.
And then asked,
whether or not, when
we expressed this sort
of poisoned pioneer,
whether or not it would affect
the binding of nearby factors.
And, in fact, when
you do express
the sort of poison
pioneer, it does
reduce the binding
of nearby factors.
Here, we have a dominant
negative for NFYA
and dominant negative for NRF1.
It reduces the binding
of nearby factors.
And finally, we wanted
to know, if we included
a dominant negative for
the directional pioneer,
if it actually
would preferentially
affect the binding
of [INAUDIBLE] on one
side of its binding
occurrences or the other side.
And so we looked
at mix sites that
were oriented with
respect to NFYA.
And when we add
the NFYA, you can
see that it actually-- the
dominant negative NFYA-- when
the mix site is down of where
we think NFYA is opening up
the chromatin, the binding
is substantially reduced.
Whereas, when the
Myc site is not
on the side where we think
that NFYA is opening,
it doesn't really
have an effect.
So this is further
confirmation of the idea
that in vivo, these
factors are actually
operating in a directional way.
Now I tell you all
this because, you know,
we do a lot of
computational analysis
and it's important to
follow up and understand
what the correlations tell us.
So when you do
computational analysis
and you see a very
interesting pattern,
the thing to keep in mind
is, what kind of experiment
can I design to
test whether or not
my hypothesis is correct or not?
We also did an analysis across
human and mouse data sets
and found that
for a given motif,
and thus, protein
family, it appeared
that the chromatin
opening index was largely
preserved, evolutionarily.
So that there are
similar pioneers
between human and mouse.
Are there any questions
at all about the idea?
So I told you, I mean, when you
go to cocktail party tonight,
you say hey, you know, did
you know that DNase-seq
is this really cool technique
that not only tells you
whether or not chromatin is
open or not, but, you know,
where factors bind?
And some of those factors
open up the chromatin itself
and, plus, get this,
some of the factors only
do it in one direction, right.
That'd be a good
conversation starter, right?
That'd be the end of
the conversation, no.
You get the idea, right.
So are there any questions
about DNase-1 seq analysis?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: A little unrelated,
but I was just wondering--
in the literature where people
have identified factors that
neither directly reprogram
between different cell types,
or go through some sort of
[INAUDIBLE] intermediate--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: There are a number
of transcription factors
that have been
identified. [INAUDIBLE]
but there are others.
Do you often see, or always
see some of the pioneers
that you've identified
in those cases.
And then--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then,
a follow-up question
would be, do you think that if
you took some of the pioneers
that you generated that
were not known before
and expressed them
in cell types,
that they would open
up the chromatin
sufficiently to potentially
reprogram the mistakes?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the question
was, is it the case
that known
reprogramming factors,
at times are powerful pioneers?
The answer is yes.
The second question was,
now that you have a broader
repertoire of pioneer
factors, and you
can identify what they're
doing, is a possible to,
in a principled way, engineer
the opening of chromatin
by perhaps expressing those
factors to see whether or not
you could match a particular
desired epigenetic state,
let's say?
Our preliminary results are yes
on the second count as well.
That there appear to
be pioneer factors that
operate, sort of at a
basal level that keep,
sort of, the sort of usual
rooms open in the genome.
And then there are
factors that operate
in a lineage-specific
specific way.
And when we express
lineage-specific pioneer
factors, they don't completely
mimic but largely mimic
the chromatin state
that's present
in the corresponding
lineage committed cells.
And so we think that for
principal reprogramming
of cells, the basal level
of establishing matched
open states is going to be
an interesting and important
avenue to explore.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah.
OK.
So, now we're going to
turn to another-- well let
me just first summarise
what I just told you about,
which is that we
can predict where
TFs bind from DNase-seq data.
We can identify these
pioneer factors.
Some of them are directional.
And other factors follow
these pioneers and bind
sort of in their wake.
In where they are actually
open up the chromatin.
And returning to our
narrative arc for today,
we've talked about the
idea of histone marks.
We've talked about the
idea of chromatin openness
and closeness.
And now I'd like to talk about
the important question of how
we can understand which
regulatory regions are
regulating which genes.
Now the traditional
way to approach this,
is that if you have a regulatory
region, the thing that you do
is you look for
the closest gene.
And you go, aha, that's the one
that that regulatory region is
controlling.
This applies not only
for regulatory regions
but for snips, right.
If you find a snip
or a polymorphism
you are likely to
assume that it's
regulating the closest gene.
It could have an effect
on the closest gene.
But there are other ways of
approaching that question
with molecular protocols.
And drawing you once again
a cartoon of genome looping,
you can see how an enhancer is
coming in contact with the Pol
II holoenzyme apparatus.
And this enhancer will
include regulators
that will cause Pol II
to begin transcription.
And if somehow we could
capture these complexes
so that we could examine them
and figure out what bits of DNA
are associated with
one another, we
could map, directly, what
enhancers are controlling what
genes, when they're
active in this form.
So the essential idea of a
variety of different protocols,
whether it be protocols
like high c or ChIA-PET
that we're going to
talk about are the same.
The difference is that
in the case of ChIA-PET,
we're only going to look
at interactions that
are defined by a
particular protein.
So what we're going to do in
the slides I'm going to show you
today, is we're
going to only look
at interactions that are
mediated through RNA polymerase
II.
And those are particularly
interesting interactions
as you can see,
because they involve
actively transcribed genes.
So if we could capture all
the RNA polymerase II mediated
interactions, we'd
be in great shape.
So, we have a lot of very
talented biologists here.
So would anybody like to make
a suggestion for a protocol
for actually revealing
these interactions?
Does anybody have any ideas
how you'd go about that?
Or what enzyme
might be involved?
Any ideas?
Don't be bashful now.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How about fixing
everything in place where it is
and then getting
[INAUDIBLE] through DNA.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Fixing everything
where it is in place.
That's good.
So we might cross link this
whole thing, for example.
OK.
And then any other
ideas what we would do?
That's done, this
protical-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE] that
you've going to be [INAUDIBLE].
And then digesting the
DNA that's coming out,
and then that lingers
to the DNA that
are closest together
in the sequence.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I think what you're
suggesting goes something
like this.
All right.
Which is, that imagine that
we cross link those complexes
and we precipitate them.
And then what we do is we,
in a very dilute solution,
we ligate the DNA together.
And so we get two kinds
of ligation products.
On the left-hand side we
get self-ligation products
where a DNA molecule
ligates to itself.
And on the right-hand side we
get inner ligation products,
where the piece of DNA
that the enhancer was on,
ligates to the pieces of DNA
that the RNA polymerase was
transcribing the gene on.
And those inter-ligation
bits of DNA,
the ones that are red and blue,
are really interesting, right.
Because they contain both
the enhancer sequence
and the promoter sequence.
And all we need to do now is
to sequence those molecules
from the ends and figure out
where they are in the genome.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How much variation
would there be in the sequence?
I guess I'm just wondering-- the
RNA polymerase is not static,
is it?
In terms of its interaction
with the intenser and the gene.
I just don't know what
would be capturing in this--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't just
touch at the beginning
and then [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
And I think that's a
very good question.
And in fact, a PhD thesis was
just written on this topic.
Which is, when you have
proteins that are moving down
the genome, in
some sense, you're
looking at a blurred picture.
So how do you
de-blur the picture
so that it's brought
sharply into focus?
And so a compute is something
called a point spread function
which describes how things are
spread out down the genome.
And then you invert that to get
a more focused picture of where
the protein is actually,
primarily located.
But you're right.
Things like RNA
polymerase II are not
thought of as
point-binding proteins.
They're actually proteins
in motion most time
when they're doing their work.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that it's polymerizing,
does that it mean that it's
still continually bound
to the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
Although, I don't
think we really
understand all of the
details of that mechanism.
But, suffice to say
that what I can do
is I can start showing
you data and from the data
we can try and
understand mechanism.
These are all great
questions, right.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When we did the
citations and ligation,
you're going to get a lot
of random ligation, right?
PROFESSOR: A lot
of random ligation?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, between DNA
sequences that aren't aren't, I
guess, as close?
Or you shouldn't really be
ligating certain things?
PROFESSOR: Well, this picture is
a little bit deceiving, right?
Because there's actually another
complex just like the one
at the top, right
to its left, right?
And you could imagine those
things ligating together.
And so now you're going to
get ligation products that
are noise.
They don't mean anything.
AUDIENCE: Do you just
throw those out, I guess?
PROFESSOR: Well, the problem is,
you don't know which ones are
noise and which ones aren't.
Right?
Now, there are some clever
tricks you can play.
One clever trick is
to change the protocol
to do these kinds
of reactions, not
in solution, but
in some sort of gel
or other thing that
keeps the products apart.
The other thing you
can do is estimate
how bad the situation is.
And how might you do that?
What you do is, you
take one set of-- you
take your original preparation
and you split it into two.
OK.
And you color this one red and
this one blue using linkers,
right.
And then you put them together
and you do this reaction.
And then you ask,
how many molecules
have the red and the
blue linkers on them.
And then you know those are
bad ones because they actually
came from different
complexes, right.
And so by estimating the amount
of critical chimeric products
you get, from that split and
then recombined approach,
you can optimize the protocol to
reduce the chimeric production
rate.
Current chimeric production
rates are about 20%.
Something of that order.
OK.
It used to be 50%,
that's really bad.
OK.
So you can try
and optimize that.
Now, if the protocol
has these issues--
you have a moving protein
that was brought up here,
right, that you're
trying to capture.
You've got a lot of noise
coming from the background
of these reactions, right.
Why are we doing this?
Well, it's the only
game in town right now.
If you want to have
a mechanistic way
of understanding what enhancers
are communicating with what
genes, this and its
family-- I broadly
call this a family
of protocols--
is really the only way to go.
OK.
The interesting thing
is that when you do,
you get data like this.
And so, what you're
looking at here
is exactly the same
location in the genome.
It's about 600,000 bases
across from left to right.
OK.
And at the very bottom,
you see the SOX2 gene.
And you have three
different cellular states.
The top state--
our motor neurons
have been programmed through
the ectopic expression
of three transcription factors.
The second set of
interactions are motor neurons
that have been
produced by exposure
to small molecules
over a 7-day period.
And the bottom set
of interactions
are from mouse ES cells
that are plueripotent.
And what's interesting
is that you
can see how-- I'm
going to point here.
You can see here-- this is the
SOX2 gene down at the bottom.
And you can see here--
this regulatory region
is interacting heavily with
the SOX2 gene at the ESL state.
And above here, I have
put SOX2 ChIP-seq data.
So you can actually see that
SOX2 is regulating itself.
And up here, we have the
same SOX2 gene locus.
And OLIG2 is a key regulator
of this motor neuron fate.
And you can see that it
appears that OLIG2 is now
regulating SOX2.
And we don't have as complete
dependence upon the SOX2 locus
as we had before.
And up here in the induced
motor neuron state,
LHX4 is one of the
reprogramming factors
and you can see how it is
interacting with SOX2 here
and over here.
So what this methodology
allows us to do,
is to tie these regulatory
regions to the genes
that they are regulating,
albeit it with some issues.
So, we'll talk about the
issues in just a second.
Are there any questions at all
about the idea of capturing,
in essence, the folding of the
genome with this methodology
to link regulatory
regions to genes?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So in each of
those charts you've
got parts describing regions
that are interacting.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that correct?
The little loops underneath
are the actual read pairs
that came out of the sequencer.
And the green dotted
lines are the interactions
I'm suggesting are significant.
So I'm showing you
the raw data and I'm
showing you the hypothesized
or purported interactions
with the green dotted lines.
Right?
AUDIENCE: So how is you raw
sequencing then transformed
into this set of interactions?
PROFESSOR: How is the raw
sequencing data-- remember
that what came out
of the protocol
were molecules on the
right-hand side that
had little bits of DNA from two
different places in the genome.
AUDIENCE: I'm
sorry, I meant, how
did you determine-- because
I'm assuming each of these arcs
has to have a single base start
side and a single base end
site.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
AUDIENCE: However,
your reads are
going to span-- your
joined paired reads are
going to span a number of bases.
So you have a number
of bases coming
from the red part
and a number of bases
coming from the blue part.
PROFESSOR: We've got
20, 20 something, yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you determine
which of these red bases
and which of these blue
bases are your start
and end points for
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, you are
looking at a 600,000 base pair
window of the
genome and we're not
quite at the resolution
of 28 bases yet.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So, you know--
AUDIENCE: So this is not
necessarily single base pair
resolution, but this
is a region resolution?
Is that correct?
PROFESSOR: Once
again, the question
of how to improve the spatial
resolution of these results
is a subject of active research.
And once again, you
can deconvolve things
like the shearing to
actually get things
down to within, say, 10 to
100 base pairs resolution.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK?
AUDIENCE: Got it.
PROFESSOR: But you can't
identify the exact motif
that the things land on, right.
They can get in the
ballpark, so to speak, right.
You can figure out where
you need to look for motifs.
And so one thing
that we and others do
is look at these
regions and we ask
what motifs are present
into these regions.
Or if you have match DNase-seq
data, you can go back
and you can say, aha,
I have DNase-seq data.
I have this data and
I know that there's
something going on at
that region of the genome.
What proteins do I
think are sitting there,
based upon the protection
profiles I see.
Right.
So you can take an
integrative approach
where you use different
data types to begin
to pick apart the
regulatory network.
Where you see the connections
directly molecularly,
and you see the
regulatory proteins
that are binding
at those locations.
OK?
Was that helpful?
Good.
Good questions.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would you consider
Hi-C and 5C and all of those
to be the same
family of technique?
PROFESSOR: I would.
They're all, sort of the same
family and they're improving.
I'm about to tell you why
this doesn't work very well.
But, that said, it's the
best thing we have going.
Right.
5C is not any to any.
It's to one to any.
This protocol, when you do
one experiment with this,
it tells you all the interacting
regions in the genome.
Right.
I believe 5C-- help
me if I'm wrong.
You pick one anchor
location and then
you can tell all the
regions and genomes that
are interacting with
that anchor location.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that 3C?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: 3C's one to one.
4C's one to any.
AUDIENCE: And 5C is--
AUDIENCE: 5C's any to any.
PROFESSOR: And 5C's any to any?
OK.
I stand correct.
Thank you.
Yeah.
OK.
You didn't critique
my bond type.
See I was trying to
get you and you didn't.
OK.
And other questions about this?
What could go wrong?
Well, I can tell you
what will go wrong.
What will go wrong is that it
has a low true positive rate.
OK.
And how can you tell that?
You do the experiment
twice and you
get thousands of interactions
from each experiment in exactly
matched conditions and
there's a very small overlap
between the conditions.
Oops.
So, that's a pretty
big oops, right?
Because you would like it
to be the case that when
you do an experiment multiple
times, you get the same answer.
So let us just
suppose that you get
10,000 interactions
in experiment one.
10,000 interactions in
experiment two, but only
2,000 of them are the same.
What could possibly
be going wrong?
Any ideas?
If you're looking at the
data, what would you think?
Well?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
could be really high,
so you're just seeing
a couple of things
that are above the background.
And they don't necessarily--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So is it maybe
that, you know, it's
just tough to get
these interactions out.
And so you got a lot
of background trash.
And the things that
are significant
are tough to pick out.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's a real
biological noise issue?
So rather than the technique,
actually any given time that
the interactions as so diverse
that when you take the snap
shot you can't--
PROFESSOR: I like
that explanation
because it's very pleasing
and makes me feel good.
And I would be hopeful
that that would be true
that there's enough biological
noise that that's actually
what I'm observing.
It doesn't make me feel
too warm and fuzzy,
but you know, I'd
go with that, right.
The other thing you
might think is, gee,
if we just sequenced
that library more,
we'd get more interactions
out them, right?
So you go off and you compute
the library complexity
of your library and you go,
oops, that's not going to work.
There just isn't enough
diversity in the library.
Meaning that the underlying
biological protocol did not
produce enough of those
interesting inner ligation
events to allow you to reveal
more information about what's
going on.
OK.
Now if I ask you to judge the
significance of an interaction
pair here.
Let's think about
this using what
we know already
from the subject.
OK.
So I'm going to draw a picture.
So I have my genome.
And let's just say that I have
a location, CA and a location CB
and I have a pile of ends that
wind up in those two locations.
OK.
And what I would like
to know is-- and I have,
let me just see what
variable I used for this.
And I have a certain number of
interactions between a and b.
That is I have a certain
number of reads that
cross between these two
locations in the genome.
And I'd like to know whether
or not this number of reads
is significant.
OK.
How could I estimate that?
Any ideas?
Oh, I'm also going
to tell you that n
is the total number
of read ends observed.
OK.
Well, here is the idea.
I've got n total
read ends, right?
I've got ca read ends here.
I've got cv read
ends here, and I
have iab that are overlapping.
So now, this is just our old
friend, the hypergeometric,
right.
We can ask what is the
probability of that happening
at random?
This many interactions or
fewer would happen at random.
And if it's very
unlikely, we would
reject the null hypothesis
and accept that there's really
an interaction going on here.
OK?
So, just to be more
precise about that.
This is what it looks like.
You've seen this before.
That the probability of
those interactions happening
on a null model, given a total
number of interactions end in
ca and cb is given by
the hypergeometric.
OK.
So that's one way of going
about assessing whether or not
the interactions we
see are significant.
Now, let me ask you a
slightly different question.
Right.
Imagine that I have-- and
I'm being very generous here.
Imagine that I have
two experiment-- that's
the wrong size bubbles.
I don't want to mislead you.
One of your friends
comes to you and say,
"I've done this
experiment twice."
Twice, OK.
"And each time I get
1,000 interactions.
So each one gives
you 1,000, let's say.
And I have 900 that are common
between the two replicates.
And your friend says,
"how many interactions
do you think there
are in total?"
How could we estimate that?
Well, what's interesting
about this problem
is that what we're
asking is what's n?
Right.
What's the total number of
interactions of which we're
observing this set and this set
of which 900 is overlapping.
There's the hyperlink
geometric again.
So all we need to do is to find
the maximum value, the best
value for n that predicts the
observed overlap given that we
have two experiments
of size, with m
and n different observations,
and we have an overlap of k.
OK.
Does that makes
sense to everybody?
Of how to estimate the
total number of interactions
out there making a
set of assumption that
they're all equally likely.
Any questions about that at all?
OK.
And, just so you know, you can
approximate this, this way.
Which is that the maximum
likelihood estimate
of the total number
of interactions
is approximately
n times n over k,
as seen by the
approximation on the bottom.
OK?
Just so that you can
approximate how many things
are out there that you
haven't seen when you've
done a couple of replicates.
OK, you guys have
been totally great.
We've talked about a
lot of different things
today in chromatin
architecture and structure.
Sort of the DC to light
version of chromatin structure
and architecture lecture.
Next time we're going
to talk about building
genetic models of EQTLs.
And the time after
that we're going
to talk about human genetics.
Thank you so much.
Have a great, long weekend.
We'll see you next Thursday.